hello everyone I hope you're all having
an excellent day and if any case you are
not then this crazy game will surely
improve it it's another game between
Norwegian International Master Owosso
stable avec also known as I am a lot
less on leeches and Leela just zero
now as the title suggests the game
features a crazy Queen sacrifice where
we're all of us could have decided to go
a different route but as lela lela I
decided to play aggressively and also I
wanted to grab some material so did
solid Lola's and basically the end
result is a very interesting game which
I'm sure all of you will enjoy very much
so let's let's check it out it's also
one of the games from their match I
believe it's a game number 8 you can
also check it out there's a link in the
description below could be game number 7
but I'm pretty sure is the number 8 but
let's check it out so Louis opens with
the Knight to f3 the reti opening we
have Knight to f6 g3 d5 and mousey for
Lila accepts the pawn D captures on c4
and the bishop to g2 and Bishop to e6
so already Lila develops the bishop to
do kind of a weird Square from where it
guards the c4 pawn it doesn't allow us
to go for Queen to a4 check to pick up
the pawn back and also the Queen now
isn't able to go to b3 to pressure to b7
pawn so all in all an interesting
decision Bishop to e6
we have castles Knight to c6 and now
Knight to g5 Louis goes for this
awkwardly placed the bishop on e6 and
here possible ideas are maybe Bishop
back to the 7 if you don't want to allow
your pawns to be doubled here but white
wood white really doesn't want to give
up his strong light square bishop for
this night even for even for triple
points so here we have Bishop to g4 by
Leela and now a lot of us goes in nice
to a3 he develops tonight to the rim of
the board but from there it will be able
to recapture on c4
another idea was actually Queen to a4
but I will just show this line because
it's a very interesting line you give up
your porn on e2 and after Bishop
captures I need to you go Bishop
captures on c6 pawn captures Queen
captures
this comes with check and now you can't
block with the Queen of course because
you lose the rook so after Knight blocks
97 now you of course play rook to e1
first as your rook is attacked and I've
won Bishop to d3 and now you can play
Queen to f3 and this basically forces a
draw because now you're threatening
Queen captures on f7 checkmate after
black responds Knight to f6 you have
Queen to c6 back and this is this is
basically a draw so if you were playing
against for example you had this
position against 200 or 300 stronger
rated opponent which which might be the
case in this matchup Louis vs Libra then
this could have been an idea but it's a
rapid game you know it's played mm-hmm
pretty much just for fun so nice 283 we
have a nice 2d for Bishop captures on b7
and this was the moment where Louis also
decided to play a very interesting game
instead of this now Lilla is going for
this e to point you could block this
would have three you could also play
rook to e1 and not allow we let the
capture need to but Louis goes for
Bishop captures from b7 which is
basically a queen sacrifice Lilla
accepts this Knight captures any two
would check and now it doesn't matter
where the King goes if Kingi - then
nights before this will check the King
also pick up the Queen and the one in
the game King - h1 was played now comes
the knife to g3 this comes with check F
captors and g3 and Bishop captures and
b1 so given up the queen but now white
will have a very dangerous attack Bishop
the c6 check and the King has nowhere to
go
your only moves are either you're gonna
block it with the Queen or with it the
night so of course nice to d7 is played
and now if you if you grab if you grab
the piece here for example rook captures
then I can simply play east six he will
developed and develop and all will be
well
you no longer have a rockin f1 to
pressure f7 so in the game instead of
capturing Louis played Knight captures
on f7 attacking the Queen and also the
rook here we have Quinta c8 as the Queen
OH
so needs to be protecting the 97 here
Knight to e5 again attacking the pinned
piece on d7 you could also play knife
captures on h8 I mean that's a full rook
just waiting there to be captured but
after Bishop to h5 Blackwell guard f7
and whites attack will definitely slow
down but it's definitely a viable option
I mean our full rook is a full rook
so after Queen to c8 nights the e5
lola's doesn't want to capture the
rookie once the he wants to finish this
game in in a very elegant way and this
is one of the things that are very
enjoyable when you're playing against
lila if you were playing against just an
engine you know if we were playing
against stockfish you would know that
things are these things like this are
not possible you will not checkmate
stockfish I mean come on but when you're
playing against a lila a neural an
artificial intelligence with a neural
net that is self-thought than me maybe
she overlooks the checkmate you never
know so as we said nice to e5 and here
we have Bishop to e2 here Bishop to g4
is also an idea to maybe guard to d7
although you will give up the bishop but
at least you won't be giving up more
material here so Bishop to e2 attacking
the rook and here hook to e1 if you play
Bishop captures on d7 yes you do win
back the Queen for example Queen
captures Knight capture some b7 but now
better captures rook on f1 I have to
remove the knight back and simply
develop and after a couple of more moves
captures captures and Bishop to g7 both
sides will have five pawns but Lila will
have will be up and exchange a rook
basically for a knight so this will be
winning for black so instead you can
immediately go for this first rook to e1
you get the rock out of the way to d3
and now again you have to you have to
decide what to do you could capture but
again you're gonna you're gonna go into
a we're safe game early
worst endgame and probably if all of us
was playing this against I don't know if
it was a really important game or
something he would definitely do this
but he still wants to checkmate Leah
so he goes b3 now you can't catch
here because then your bishop and III
would be hanging here Bishop to f5 now
the night and d7 is defended and no
longer there is an option of actually
capturing it we have night a captures on
c4 and by doing this lawless has gotten
this night from a3 back into the game
and he will still start he will still
try to checkmate the black king one of
the ideas is definitely Bishop to d5
followed by Bishop to f7 check King
moves and then Knight will come to c6 to
checkmate the black king
but how will how will I stop this in the
game she played h5 and H 5 is definitely
a weird-looking move I mean what's the
idea behind h5 well you're kind of
allowing this rook to come back into the
game but is that really so important at
the moment it doesn't it doesn't appear
to be you know maybe maybe playing the
other pawn would be more reasonable but
as far as I can see it's it's basically
an attacking move if white for some
reason decided to capture the rook and
Queen captures then h4 would be kind of
dangerous but but who knows why h5 was
played so ok d4 preparing to develop the
bishop also there it nicely supports the
knight on e5 we have a 5 now so first h5
now a5 preparing to develop the route
from a8 and here Bishop to d5 this is
what I meant if you now for example
captured and Queen captures would check
King moves and then h4 can be very
dangerous because now the rockin H it
becomes very active so after a 5 we have
Bishop to d5 now threatening the idea we
mentioned Bishop to f7 checked followed
by Knight to c6 checkmate
rook to a6 now and now of course this is
the reason why if I was played now you
can develop your look and also guard
this square Bishop to f7 check rook to
d8 pin to d8 and now you can see if this
rook wasn't here then Knight to c6 would
be a beautiful smothered mate but
unfortunately for all of us this rook is
an a6
so he has to try something else Bishop
to f4 now getting another piece into the
game but now comes
to be seven check kink the g1 and now e
six finally the spawn is pushed and the
bishop can come into the game rook a to
d1 now comes Knight captures Bishop to
g5 check King
runs away from the semi open file rook
captures an e5 and now Bishop to d6
offering basically a bishop for a knight
but also forcing the rook to move here
Knight to a5 was played capturing that
capturing that porn also attacking the
Queen and b7 and here early was simply
played Queen to f3 and it was in this
position that international master lost
a bollock resigned the game because
simply too many pieces are hanging the
rock on e5 is attacked the knight on e5
is attacked if the rook moves the rook
on d1 is completely undefended so too
many piece hanging here there's really
nothing to do here if you played rook to
f1 you get the rock out of the way with
a tempo on the Queen then Queen to g4
and now your Bishop on g5 is attacked
also the rook is still attacked the
night is still attacked on a5 and after
Bishop to a for getting the bishop
parted way now simply captured now
simply captures captures and of course
you captured the knight and the white
will be down to too much material to
even consider playing this so yeah after
this Queen to have to remove all also
resigned to the game and a wonderful
victory for a lil hs0 so it was a I mean
it was a beautiful game for both of them
although us really made a beautiful
Queen sacrifice and it was a it was very
instructive how Lila defended against
such a jerk such a crazy attack so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I don't believe I'll be showing any more
Leela games until her until her Sunday
match with with Andrew tank also known
as the penguin so until then we might
check up on some games from the US
Championship or we'll see if there are
any any interesting games in your
suggestions I would like to thank Simone
but give it's Rachel Simmons Norman
stone and Dirk Elsevier's for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previously
here I think of for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with another
interesting video thank you